why did we choose this life why did we
become superheroes we dedicate our lives
to fighting crime for one reason to make
a billion dollars on a superhero
franchise now let's go through the plan
one more time
first we start with a movie then we
do the super Craig movie then super
Craig and kun will join forces in the
human kite movie just as we start
ramping up Kenny's Netflix series how
come I have to have the Netflix series I
want a movie - you have a movie
mysterion you're in the third and
friends united movie after your Netflix
series yeah but II think he doesn't ever
get his own movie do I get my own movie
not everyone gets their own movie the
franchise plan sucks if we want to make
billions of dollars and I think we
should start with the Tupperware movie
right start with a black superhero
Marvel is making a black superhero movie
yeah now they we need you to get to that
we follow their plan we do all the real
people first and we sneak the black guy
in at page three how about we just do
movie starring all of us like all the
time
but then we're just rehashing the same
old material there's nothing wrong with
doing the exact same movie to start a
franchise okay JJ Abrams okay oh okay so
you're on Carmen's side he just likes
this plan because he gets to movies and
face1 yeah we have to just go with this
plan we don't even have one movie yet
how did it get to this how did we grow
up so far apart
you go with the plan maybe we'll just go
and do our own franchise yeah yeah oh
you want subawardees how would you want
yeah dude Civil War you you get out of
my house
we'll make way more money on our
franchise go ahead that you need to get
halfway through phase 1 on your
franchise DC Comics I thought Civil War
wasn't supposed to happen - till phase 3
shut up super Craig
I didn't want to have to do this but you
leave me no choice did I just hear
someone using microaggression
hey youtubers is Charlie so South Park
just released a new game if you guys
didn't know they just totally destroyed
Marvel and DC so we have to talk about
this
sometimes South Park feels like it's
going nowhere and sometimes it feels
like pure genius and this wound up being
a total slam-dunk when they first
announced this game last year I had
absolutely no idea what the title meant
I was like this sounds like nothing
whatever and I just forgot about it but
in the context of this trailer it
totally makes sense
they're basically doing Captain
America's Civil War but it's Batman V
Superman versus Captain America Civil
War and if you missed the Washington
Redskins episode a couple seasons ago
they also do one of Cartman's funny
franchise plans this is our business
plan this chalkboard is a work of art it
hasn't been a bunch of funny names of
characters for funny movies that they're
gonna do is part of the story of how
they're trying to make movies the way
Marvel makes movies and plot them out
but they also poke fun at Marvel for
sneaking the black guy in in Phase three
deciding which characters like the
are good enough to start off phase one
who gets two movies during that phase
who starts out in the Netflix series
then works his way into the big team up
movie and then you have the big team-up
Avengers movies and friends one
and friends - Armageddon and
friends three United with mysterion
mysterion is probably like the
spider-man character you've got your
villain movie your Suicide Squad team up
movie professor chaos squad and then
they also have a whole bunch of DC jokes
on here - like vs. super Craig so
this is super meta like you could just
pause this and look at it and just look
at all the things and guess what they're
making fun of at each of these titles
they've even plotted out a latin america
only movie release Kuni amigos
so when South Park does stuff like this
when they're firing on all cylinders
doing something that's very topical and
recent they're just pure genius
so while deadpool takes the piss out of
superhero genre Southpark really takes
the piss out of hollywood in general
they just do a much better job of it in
what I'm expecting is because this is a
video game they're gonna mirror a lot of
shots from Captain America Civil War
Batman V Superman so just look for
Easter eggs in the way battle shape up
and the cutscenes but the basic story of
the game is is that they're trying to
make all these movie it's and
friends like Cartman tries to organize
all these superheroes like they did in
the and friends episodes a couple
seasons ago they're going to make a
bunch of movies but they can't
who's gonna be in what movie how this is
all gonna work out and that's what
causes Civil War so then as they're
walking away you realize that like half
of the table was DC and the other half
was Marvel characters DC you're not even
gonna get halfway through phase 1 so it
makes you wonder how much of this they
added late because all the drama with
Batman V Superman didn't happen until
this year I mean people were worried
about the film last year but it takes a
long time to make video games so I'm
guessing they added a lot of this
context very recently because they
wouldn't have even seen Captain America
Civil War 2 this spring but if you're
wondering when South Park makes fun of
Hollywood franchises and characters like
this they don't have to get permission
sometimes they do like Family Guy got
Lucas Films permission when they did the
Star Wars episodes but this is really
South Park doing a meta send up of all
these things combined rather than Family
Guy which was doing like a shot-for-shot
remake of the Star Wars movies so it's
kind of a different case but this week
we have reached peak shut up and take my
money so is e3 goes on there's a bunch
of titles that I've pre-ordered
typically for those of you that ask most
of my pre-orders for consoles or ps4
just because so many more people play on
that console but Microsoft is flipping
on the ability for you to buy a console
exclusive and also play it on your PC
like you get a free digital download for
your PC but it's not for every single
Xbox game it's only for Xbox exclusive
titles like Gears of War
so with games like Southpark they get
released on all consoles and PC I'd
recommend you stick with whatever
primary platform you game on but
important stuff if I didn't say it
already
the game is out December 6 so be sure to
check it out and a lot of you were
asking me about spider-man there was a
really cool spider-man ps4 trailer I'll
do a video for that tomorrow because
it'll be based on Tom Hollands new
version of the character
there'll be Easter eggs for the movies
but the story of the game isn't going to
be exactly what the story of the movies
gonna be there will be a little
crossover like the way the suit works
with a stark tech so I'll explain that
tomorrow I totally love South Park so
much especially when they do stuff like
this but why use wait for my next video
to post
here for my Game of Thrones trailer for
next week's episode and you can click
here for my injustice 2 gameplay trailer
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you